Rebecca is with us in Indianapolis I
Rebecca how are you I'm good thanks how
are you better than I deserve what's up
okay I just started listening to your
show about a month ago and I'm loving it
and I have a question for you about
whether I should fix my car or replace
it okay
my so the air conditioning broke on it
about a month ago actually this was not
the end of the world because I walked to
work most days it's going to cost about
$800 to fix it and there's a couple
other things broken on it too but it
doesn't impact how the car runs it's
worth fifteen hundred dollars and it has
just under 100,000 miles on it okay here
is a mathematical formula on a on a
hoopty like that as to whether you fix
it or turn it into the junkyard and use
the money or not to fix it okay so what
would it sell for as is with a broken
air conditioner well I put in two kelley
blue book and it came up 1,500 but I
didn't put the a/c was broken so maybe
under a thousand okay let's pretend for
a minute that it was 900 okay let's say
itself for nine hundred dollars as is if
you take 900 and you put 800 dollars
invested in it you now have $1,700 in a
car that's worth fourteen or fifteen
hundred yeah
you follow me okay so if that's the real
numbers you would not fix the car you
would sell it for nine hundred take the
eight hundred you were going to spend on
the a/c put it with your nine hundred
and buy a better car album and but if
it's worth only six hundred without the
a/c fixed
then that's 1400 with your 800 right
yeah you wouldn't have more in the car
then than it's worth so you would
probably fix it in that case what I'm
going to do in your situation is I'm
going to try to find another way to get
the AC fix cheaper maybe a used AC from
a junkyard and maybe a shade tree to
help you put it on of some kind rather
than spending quite 800 bucks I bet
there's another way to get at this and
get it working again and then maybe sell
it this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]